[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 86 of
the weekly Google classroom podcast
hi I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with
my colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how
are you doing
I am good how are you doing very good
back from Denver for go freak on
enjoying the beautiful weather in San
Francisco
well you are in very warm weather in New
York very very very one way I'm sure I
feel like it's appropriately warm I
really like warm weather San Francisco
is never quite warm enough yeah yeah
yeah I disagree but anyway today we're
gonna have really interesting
conversation with actually two people
from two very different areas one is a
Googler and manages platinum customer
account and the other one is an engineer
from Broad Institute which happens to be
a platinum customer and they're gonna be
telling us all about what does it mean
to be a platinum customer well the
benefit what kind of things they do it
is really interesting it's like we've
been having a couple episodes on like
essary and crüe and like how customers
and Googlers partner in to like their
adventures so we're gonna keep on
talking about that basically yeah yeah
no it's a really interesting
conversation about the multitude of ways
that Google cloud platform and Google
itself can help customers of ours to
help be successful which is quite cool
yeah and some cool stories at the end of
the episode and at the end after those
cool stories we'll have a question of
the week as usual and this time comes
from gopher Khan actually someone came
up to the booth the Google clappa phone
booth that we had and they had a
question about how to do it to basically
expose a kubernetes service without
having to pay for a load balancer which
makes sense only for very tiny clusters
for like QA and stuff like that but it's
definitely cool idea and good to know
how to do it so we'll cover that at the
end cool all right well why don't we get
stuck into our cool things of the week
sounds good the first one even though is
about Europe and I am definitely
European is about something
I do not know that much I gotta let you
go and explain to us what this really
means cool
so at the top of the story is that we
are now have a new region open in London
so another region urban Europe which is
pretty cool
we have a few more snow coming in
Finland Netherlands and Frankfurt and
we've got a variety of products from
from there from auto scalars to
container engine to App Engine to data
lab etc I think the interesting part
here and I am definitely not a lawyer so
I would redirect you to the show notes
so you can read the article properly we
did write a blog post recently
announcing basically our commitment to
the general data protection regulation
which takes effect in May 2008 een for
those of you who aren't familiar it's
basically privacy privacy legislation
that goes into effect across Europe and
so we want to make sure that that's good
for all our European customers again I'm
not a lawyer so I'm gonna redirect you
to the blog posts to read through it all
that'll be in the show notes but this is
just you know one more step in that
direction just to say hey like we take
this really seriously so we're opening
our region in London and we're also
making sure we're compliant a second
cool thing of the week and this one I
Twitter about it because as soon as I
saw it I thought it was really really
cool is our friends from the New York
Times and they were talking about how to
do continuous deployment for app engine
and container engine and they open
source all of the code which is really
cool we'll link to in the show notes
we'll find it yeah and now they open
source something else this time of up go
it's about how to use go kids on App
Engine standard environment so we've got
one the 600 on the 8 in beta currently
so for those who don't know what go kit
is I know I'm a vague idea I'm not
entirely sure why is go kit so cool and
why is it cool that it's on App Engine
go kid basically it allows you to make
your services more robust it is a micro
service framework for kept any manages
things like making sure that you have
monitor and you're able to instrument
all the read poems and security and even
things like well if a server is down you
should not keep on trying to send
requests all the time so like financial
backup and all of these things that you
need to take care of when you're writing
a proposed architecture with micro
services all of those things are
believing go kids now the problem is
that
has some limitations on what you can do
one of them is actually how you get an
HTTP connection to the outside Yanis so
basically they adapted it so you can use
App Engine and gokit together which is
pretty cool so if you're interested if
you're running go on App Engine I'll
definitely ask you to go have a look
because these actually really
interesting stuff well we talked last
week about how kubernetes 1.7 was
released so this week we're talking
about how you can now use it on
container engine which is super super
cool it's super super fast and super
super fast yeah it's amazing how quickly
these come through as well as a couple
of other interesting things in here just
for gke releases so that we've got lexo
an order or a beta for like if nodes
have any issues we have new regions and
they all have container engine which is
great as well and we've also allowed us
to have like internal load balancing is
beta as well for criminales and gke it's
like Google cloud platform so there's
like a bunch of new features that are
also available not just kubernetes ones
but gke ones that have come along with
this release as well really cool and the
last cool thing of the week before the
interview is about container builder and
we did an episode on container builder
it was episode 79 and this time we have
a video by one of our teammates Cotter
Morgan talking about I think it's gonna
be a long series because it's called
Builder part 1 but it's the first
episode of the series and these 1 covers
have to do rolling updates with
container builder and it's only 5
minutes so if you use any of these or
you curious go check it up awesome
well I think that's plenty of cool
things yeah don't we go chat with our
friends Lucas and Mike and talk all
about platinum customers and bird
Institute that today I am delighted and
overjoyed to have two fine fellows
joining us today we have Lucas at
Carlson cloud architect and developer
advocate at Broad Institute and as well
we also have Marc alterus who is a
strategic customer engineer here at
Google cloud platform as well thank you
so much for joining us how are you both
doing today Lucas great thank you for
having us excellent Mike you're doing
well as well
hey guys doing fantastic thanks for
asking wonderful
thank you for coming hey excellent so
super excited to have you on the podcast
to talk about both Broad Institute and
also being a platinum customer and what
does that actually mean but before we do
that why don't we just hear about both
of you Lucas why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do at the Broad Institute well I've been
at the broad for about fourteen years or
so so I've had quite a few different
roles over that time but right now I'm
responsible for our cloud architecture
and strategy and I also am filling a
role as developer advocate where I try
and improve the success of all of the
developers within the broad and some
external who try to consume our services
cool and for those that do not know what
it is in like a very short sentence what
is the broad institute the broad is a
genomics Research Institute funded
primarily by government grants that
focuses on sort of the analytical side
of biology and chemistry so we were one
of the major contributors responsible
for the Human Genome Project and now we
are focused on sort of proving the value
of the genome by discovering therapies
and tools that improve health and
science that's very awesome that sounds
pretty awesome and Mike what do you do
yes I'm the strategic customer engineer
that actually is assigned to the Broad
Institute that's part of our Platinum
support service that we offer for our
strategic customer if someone like
myself that is assigned specifically to
a large customer such as the broad so
you are a Googler I'm a Googler yeah I'm
actually based out of western Virginia
we are a worldwide team we have
presidents across the globe and I am
here and luckily at the same time zone
as Lukas on the East Coast
excellent all right so when we start on
the the broad institute side and then
we'll come back to the platinum
customers side of things I'm sure you
find time to switch in between but okay
so it sounds like Lukas you do a lot
with very large amounts of data do you
just run on GCP like what is what is
this pipeline look like as you do these
large so that sounds like data
calculations of some kind well we have a
really wide variety of projects going on
at the broad so anything I say about
what we're doing for one project is
likely different for some other project
we have users in most of the major
public clouds right now including Amazon
and Google and certainly data is
probably the the biggest thing for us so
when I look at our consumption of
services in the cloud you know more than
50% of what we consume is data storage
and probably a little over a third of it
is for compute and then everything else
is is things like monitoring and sequel
services and that sort of thing cool so
what products do you use on GCP so in CP
we are as I said a big storage customer
we're using some of the global and multi
regional and regional buckets primarily
although we're sort of moving towards
some of the near line and cold line
storage as well we do a massive amount
of compute parallel compute so we run
jobs that at times use let's say tens of
thousands of CPUs simultaneously and so
we're a big customer of the preemptable
vm service in fact we were I believe
Google's blog announcement customer for
that service and so this is an example
what would you be using these things for
is like you said you have a wide variety
product but now I'm just quite curious
like at a concrete level what you'd be
doing so the the most common thing that
we do with computing is we do data
analysis so we have all these
instruments that are sequencing DNA and
generating various kinds of raw data
from images to other sorts of data files
and we run these pipelines against them
which basically looks like potentially a
Python script or something that reads in
some raw data runs
UNIX tools against that data and then
takes the output from that first step
and makes that the input of the next
step and then you know flowing through a
pipeline of steps to generate some
certain kind of output that helps answer
some particular genetic question about
the data nice so I guess since we have a
I was gonna say broad idea jokes maybe
we get we can talk a little bit about
the fact that you mentioned that you are
a platinum customer what does this mean
maybe we can get Mike to answer this
question sure yes a platinum customer is
a strategic customer for Google cloud
platform we deemed those customers to be
of high important to us as a cloud
provider and we want to make sure they
get the utmost experience when it comes
to using Google cloud services and as
part of that to make sure that that's
really happening as a ski a strategic
customer engineer like myself is
dedicatedly assigned to those customers
and in a way we are the constant from
the technical perspective that they have
in Google I'm like their technical
ambassador bridging all the different
groups within Google cloud the PM's the
engineering the operational the TAM the
sales support itself and through those
providing technical advisory product
influencer and assistance with
operations so for example is bukas
mentioned there was a massive amount of
usage when they kick up those workloads
as well we have teams behind that are
kind of watching it and look and making
sure everything works properly and as it
should be and through our relationship
with Lukas myself and engineering we are
always kind of making sure that these
things are ticking away like they should
be that's one example so now I'm curious
about how are you different or similar
to CRS customer reliability engineering
yeah that's a fair question a very good
one I guess
the main difference is that we have an
account wide relationship that is
continuous and constant I'm always gonna
be there even there's gonna be one or
more CRE engaged there's always going to
be ASCII
that oversees the technical aspect of
the relationship between Broad Institute
and Google so no matter what anything
that has to be with technical aspect of
those relationship this ski is gonna be
involved and make sure everything is
moving in the right direction and
doesn't go orthogonal so yeah they're
gonna be multiple engagement there are a
technical nature through series through
professional services organizations but
it's a ski as the buck stops here when
it comes to technical aspect of the
relationship and I'm always gonna be
there to make sure it's working other
way it should so actually for two things
when when you say ski you mean
a NS C II that's just like exactly Carl
my manager is the one responsible for
coming up with this key acronym so we we
actually have a ski lodge in the amount
of the office with with skis and fake
snow and try to name all of our services
and all our offerings into kind of like
the ski related so our weekly report is
called the snowboard the broadcast okay
so and Mike you were talking about
having a continuous engagement what does
that look like do you have like weekly
meetings you in touch every day they cat
is that work totally we have we have
scheduled weekly Cadence's across
multiple teams within the broad Lukas of
course is a major part of it but it also
means hangouts and just add prop and ad
hoc situation where we just get on a
hangout and chat and discuss things so
if something needs to be addressed
either from operation product guidance
connecting to a p.m. I get hit but
abroad or I hit the road and we just
have an impromptu conversation about it
so the personal and the trust
relationship the trust aspect of the
relationship is key fact to what we
consider being a success and in kind of
making sure everything works and
reducing their anxiety about using a
platform so Lukas I was going to ask you
and I think you're proud to jump in I
what does this look like from your side
mike has open office hours that he
provides via hangout so that anyone at
the broad who is using GCP has access to
Mike and in addition we have an internal
google group of all of our GCP users in
an internal slack channel of the same
users and Mike is involved in both of
those so many times a user will ask
something in the chatroom or on the
mailing list and the response is Oh Mike
can help with that just reach out to
Mike and/or Mike will even see these
things because he he's periodically
active on these channels with us so he's
very much integrated as a member of our
team an extended member of the Broads
you know Google support team nice so so
that sounds awesome and I guess that
many of our customers that are out there
wondering how these things happen like
how these did start the way we got onto
GCP in the first place is because we
were already a G suite customer and as
we began moving into the cloud and
exploring the multiple offerings out
there you know the G suite integration
with GCP in that it's using the same
identities and we've already dealt with
the whole on-boarding and off-boarding
process of our users so that since
someone leaves the company and their G
Street account is disabled that means
they also lose access to all of the GCP
resources that they would have had so
that that's been compelling for us and
that sort of is one of the contributing
factors to us using GCP and certainly
over the last four or five years that we
have been a GCP customer our usage has
grown drastically over that time and
sort of the level of relationship that
we need to have in order to be able to
support that has grown over that time so
you know I actually can't imagine using
the services at the scale that we use
them today without having Mike involved
at this point and it's hard for me to
remember what it was like before we had
him I don't really like to think about
it so from your side Mike how did that
look for you how did you get involved
how what was the
avoiding process for you yeah the tight
relationship between myself as a ski and
the customer means that the onboarding
process is is almost like me doing a
full research about the customer their
usage reading up all the internal
documentation that we had relating to
the history that we had with broad
before me joining and just going and
drilling as deep as possible around
their usage their issues their support
cases the meeting notes everything I
could find around the background of
brode in Google interaction I consumed
it for a period of time before I got
engaged and of course from that point on
I was introduced to Lucas and slowly and
as time went by got introduced to other
members of produce titude and as issues
came up that was another opportunity to
learn even more and be given deeper
about things that they do in particular
for example broad is a big usage of our
genomics API so through the broad I
actually got a lot of opportunity to
learn and understand how our genomics
API works I got some data samples and I
ran some of the same workloads that
abroad is running by myself on our
genomics API so I can get a better
understanding of how the the things that
they do operate on our site the old kind
of pain points that they're experiencing
so I can provide better assistance and
better understanding when things happen
to how to quickly and make it solve as
quickly as possible
and then another thing that mike does
that's really helpful is he sees all of
the activity on all of our tickets so
even if it's like in the middle of the
night and i go and submit a ticket about
some issue i just discovered
when i chat with mike in the morning
he's certainly aware of that and it's
not like i have to you know bring him
speed on something that just happened he
has you know full visibility into
everything so even times when users
within the broad submit tickets that i
don't know about mike it has visibility
into that so he can sometimes make me
aware of issues that i was not aware of
previously and having that additional
context on the i guess almost like the
metadata
on the fact that broad is a large
customer and what they're doing and what
are the typical issues they have the
ability to overlay that when issue comes
up and communicate that to our back-end
to engineering to support to PMS whoever
makes the resolution and the experience
for the road much better and much more
fluid and if it has to be rediscovered
every time there's an issue so I'm
curious about your mentioning that
you're able to file issues and that you
might get them like basically directly
are those issues file the same way as
any other customer is there a special
relationship that you have how does this
work
yeah from the backend it's the same
support mechanism that all of our other
customers just the fact that I'm tapped
in right to the vein of the Brothe
activity so I see that in real time as
it happened and if I you know find a
place that I can grease the skids so to
speak and make things work a little bit
more smoother by providing additional
context I immediately get on that sit
mics are we talking about the issue
tracker here like and how we have
additional visibility there yeah that's
actually a really good point right so we
actually you know in addition to just a
general support ticketing system we
actually also a provision broad as a
partner to our internal bug and Iser
system so broad has you know a unique
component within Google's internal bug
tracking system which is a way that get
even deeper penetration and
understanding of technical issues that
are pertaining to both sides so broad
can talk directly to for example Google
genomics API engineers on specific
issues through the additional system of
the bug Nizer
so I'm putting on my hey I'm a DCP
customer hat and I'm thinking to myself
this sounds amazing I want what you all
have how does that happen is it a
certain tier of usage do we select this
based on certain internal criteria what
what's the what's the deal there Mike
yeah great question so the Skee
engagement is actually part of the
professional service organization of
google cloud so any customer can
actually reach out to
they're Google cloud representative and
asked him about the option of getting a
Technical Account Manager is key we're
making that available as a service yeah
cool well is there a URL that people can
go to if they want to find that or is
that specific to if you have already
head of a sales agent yeah absolutely so
you can definitely go to our website and
go to cloud that google.com slash
support and you should be able to
continue from there
awesome and we'll just hand out your
phone number Mike if people can't find
that I'm used to that cool so I'm
curious about is there any any story
that you can share of like how this
actually works like a concrete use case
where have being a platinum customers
solved a big problem like I don't know
if there was some some big technical
problem on your side or I don't know
like any any kind of those issues where
being a platinum customer really made a
difference yeah I mean the ones I'd like
to talk about are where we have
mistakingly exposed the lack of infinite
capacity that Google has so like there
was that first time where I got the call
where they were like what are you doing
in the central region right now and I
was like oh my gosh we just showed up on
Google's radar that's amazing like and
and we realized that they're they're
actually our limited amount of resources
and it's possible to consume them all at
some point cool so now I'm wondering is
there any story any interesting story
you can share that really shows a big
difference or like oh luckily we were
tapped in the customer if that we're
able to solve this issue is there
something like that that you can share
that it's not top secret or something
yeah so one of the things I think that
one of the reasons we are a platinum
customer is the scale at which we run is
such that we periodically are able to
expose the sort of fact that the cloud
is not actually unlimited and so in one
example you know we were using too many
CPUs in a particular repin and we had to
be very strategic with Google about
where to move those workloads
there was another situation last year
where we in using all of those
preemptable VMs that we were using we
managed to consume most of the IP
address resources in a particular region
and so we went down a very strategic
route with Google and not only
tactically trying to solve the immediate
problem but basically trying to redesign
our application and with Google to to
make it so that we didn't need to use so
many external IP addresses and it was
integration it wasn't like five or ten
like seek more than that tens of
thousands and and so you know one of our
applications needs to speak to the
Internet and so while many of Google's
resources like storage are available
using internal IP addresses if that same
machine needs to talk to like docker hub
for example then it it or something near
it needs to have a public IP so you know
we we sort of exposed this limitation in
both Google's infrastructure as well as
in the design of our application and
then Mike and his team rallied around
this was actually during a docker con
last year and so there was a few
Googlers like Mike spots Karl was at
docker con and he and I were able to get
together in a little room and just sort
of hack through the issue with a bunch
of Brodie's who were back on site in
Cambridge and with Mike and others who
were who were online at Google and it
was a really like collaborative sort of
urgent effort to try and resolve this
issue and just from from that point of
view I mean the the back-end services
and team owners are intimately aware of
Brodie Institute because of issues like
that and it actually helped us make the
platform better we change a lot of our
internal processes and also general
processes as a cloud provider as a
result of these type of interaction we
had with approaches to being a Platinum
customer and really pushing us to the
limit and and at the end of the day it
really helps all of our customers
another example I think is um you know
Mike is able to help me
interact with many of the PM's of some
of the products that we rely on very
heavily and through those relationships
were often able to get on early access
or alpha programs for certain products
and for example earlier this year we
were one of the first if not the first
customer to begin using a feature and
within the first day or two of
experimenting with it we found two major
bugs and so Google able to sort of pull
that feature resolve those bugs and get
that redeployed before any other
customers experienced it so in the end
you know we were able to get access to a
feature that was critical to us and we
were able to help Google make that
feature more reliable for everybody
and at the end taking that to the next
level as a result of all that tight
interaction we had around that feature
and function look us was actually on
annex 2017 on stage presenting some of
the code that he wrote related to that
functionality and features nice the fact
that you're building up their content
and requirement for GCP next Lucas
immediately came to mind and through the
relationship we were able to reach out
and work out a way where Lucas ends up
on stage talking about the solution
awesome well we'll find that talk and we
have a link from the show notes that's
for sure um okay so we're running out of
time and so I'd like to ask my favorite
question which is does anyone have
anything extra to add or anything we
haven't managed to ask in our interview
process so far Mike I think you might
have something yeah I think so
last point I do actually have the URL we
can go and get the in touch with the
professional services and it's a cloud
that google.com slash solutions awesome
all right Lucas Mike thank you so much
for joining us we really appreciate you
taking the time and talking to us about
bird institute and also what it means to
be a platinum customer thanks for having
us thank you guys
pleasure to be here so thanks again to
both Lucas and Mike for taking the time
today to explain a little bit about what
is to be a platinum customer what does
Intel and what is the kind of like
relationship and how like basically
helping each other all the time
pre amazing that platinum customers they
get such a level of support like they
basically can call someone a Googler
on their mobile phone directly cremating
yeah and make sure like if you have a
company that's large enough or have
enough needs that you think you need to
be a platinum customers check out the
links in the show notes so you can get
involved as quickly as possible so I
guess that it's time to go with a
request of the week and as I was saying
at the beginning of the episode this
point comes from someone but someone
that came to see me have Google apart
from booth at gopher con last week in
Denver and his question was like okay so
I have a have a development class served
for kubernetes so basically I'm running
kubernetes on gkd and and it's a it's a
development QA thing so I wanted to be
as cheap as possible because there's no
production traffic going on in there so
I don't really care about like
reliability or anything like that so I
can run it with one single instance and
I can even run it with everyone's know
which is actually very very affordable
but then when I want to expose service
if I expose it with the default way of
doing it which is by saying type it'll
load faster than also and you get a load
balancer and then you need to pay for
that load balancer which is more than
what they would like to pay specifically
for these test environment so how can
you expose service without a load
balancer and I think that you have a way
to do it so I guess you can go with one
and I'll go with the other one okay
I have I have one way that I think
should work so the way that I was gonna
say is we're saying that like there's
one we're gonna have one instance in our
criminales cluster yeah so often what
happens if you're not running kubernetes
on the cloud rather than using a service
with a type load balancer you actually
do what's called type node port which
actually opens up the port directly on
the machine and it opens up the same
port for all the services across all the
machines that are inside your clusters
so then you could put it your own load
balancer over the front just point it to
those ports across those machines and
you're good to go but there's nothing
that stops you from saying hey why don't
we just connect directly to that node
port for that individual service so you
could do a service with a node port
specify the port that you want to open
and have that available the only caveat
I would put it is just to make sure that
there is a firewall rule on that compute
engine instance that GK provisions for
you to inch
or that the traffic will go through to
that port but in theory it should work I
guess there's a second caveat to that
which goes with leads us to the other
solution which is what happens if that
instance is restarted you might get a
different IP so all of a sudden what IP
should you target so that's why this
there's a different solution which is by
using static IP s so you can set up that
get a stack Fe for your service and then
that static IP it is completely free of
charge as long as it's assigned to
something so if you're running it with
instant then you're gonna need to pay
for anything for that one which is cool
and then you can actually set on your
ingress service you can set that
specific IP details to set this up are
actually part of a little repo that
Kelsey hides our open source so we will
have a link to that specific place
basically takes you through how to
reserve static Fe and then how to add it
to your kubernetes configuration files
in order to use that one for your
service rather than allocating a new
load balancer if you wanted to get super
fancy you might be able to make it
preemptable as well so I tried and you
can I don't know I mean it is it will be
more affordable but at the same time I
wonder if if you're running tests on it
but it's only gonna go down maybe once
every 24 hours or so or more often it's
gonna know your test flaky so then you
need to rerun them again same time
integration test so probably flakiness
is okay I'm just saying it's an option
it's just there it is definitely an
option the one that is not an option
that I thought about was well don't want
to make it as affordable as possible
maybe you can run an f-1 micro because
you get one for free per month so that'd
be perfect but it is not enough to run
kubernetes unfortunately so you need to
run at least every one small which is
also very very very affordable to be
honest so so you can run kubernetes Ben
no pods basically yeah you go jig around
carbonated but nothing will run inside
so yeah not big enough yeah wonderful
before we ramble on even further
franceska what are you up to you going
anyways special I know you just got back
from graphic on yeah I just got back
from gopher concern I'm taking a couple
days off my go camping somewhere in the
forest far away from computers and yeah
and after that basically enjoying San
Francisco I'll be here for the go SF
meetup in July 26th and after that some
holidays again what about you what am i
up to let me think
so I will be attending actually so I
will be speaking at PAX dev at the end
of August in Seattle and then attending
pax after that so that'll be lots and
lots of fun before that I think just
getting ready for pax and look pretty
excited about it actually nice I guess
that I will also mention that I keep on
really thing up just for fun camp is
just for funk so by the time this
episode comes out I will be working on
the next one and there's some surprises
coming up like guest stars and stuff
like that mmm it's gonna be exciting yep
I'm excited
wonderful well Fran says thank you so
much for joining me for yet another
episode thank you Mark and enjoy the
amazing weather in New York as you love
it so much and thank you for listening
and we'll see you all next week
[Music]